all right thank you bianca we want to
turn your attention to new cova data
coming into our newsroom a bit of good
news here nevada's test positivity rate
continues to drop now standing at 12.2
percent clark county is at 10.8 percent
meanwhile the county also reporting 180
cases per every 100 000 over the last
seven days that number needs to be below
a hundred to remove the mask requirement
you can always use your phone to scan
this qr code on your screen it'll take
you straight to a breakdown of our full
covid report that's available right now
on eightnewsnow.com
and if you're still looking to get your
vaccine you can get it tomorrow at first
friday from 5 to 11 at night no
appointment is necessary more
opportunities this weekend at vacs on
the tracks taking place at the nevada
southern railway museum down in boulder
city saturday and sunday from 9 a.m to 1
p.m
also several valley high schools are
offering the vaccine on weekdays from 8
30 to 6. we have a full list on
eightnewsnow.com